last few things to talk about uh bitcoin
yeah you guys want to hear a cool story
okay so yeah by the way this whole
podcast originally started about bitcoin
i never talked about bitcoin anymore
okay this is a good one all right so
i know shabbat is saying it's so wide oh
2013. is it
no 12 2012. okay
so 2012 i went to this party um it was
called an animal print party so we all
wore animal clothing would you guys
i don't know
oh i wore like a onesie a onesie like
adult
pajama that had like zebra on it okay
and that's a shitty costume but go ahead
i was 20 something 22. i it's all it was
you got dressed up i got it from like
dollar stores some of the dollar store
okay so i met this girl i started
talking this girl we were hitting off i
was single all the time
and we were doing great and you know
this big charming guy walks in and i
like stare at him because he was wearing
like a he was wearing like a speedo an
animal print speedo and he it was like
fit and tall and a good smile and he
steals the girl from me and starts
chatting her up and i end up start
talking to the guy and i made friends
with them yada yada and uh i friended
him on facebook afterwards and um
we took we took pictures together okay
and i started following my facebook his
name was ross and um
i see
what i'll tell you i see on facebook
that he's like selling his
truck for two thousand dollars because
he posted the craigslist link i see that
he's like an equities trader on linkedin
just whatever i wasn't like close with
him but i had hung out with him that day
he stole your girl yeah yeah and so a
few weeks later maybe a few months later
i come home from my house i come to my
house in glen park and there's police at
the library i'm like what is going on
and i and somewhat terry and my friend
she goes sam ross got arrested i was
like for what he goes you know silk road
i was like yeah i know silk road she
goes he restarted silk road
holy [ __ ] and uh i knew what silk road
was like i knew what i knew a lot of i
mean it was like this like scary cool
thing
that was ross ross albright albrecht old
brick yeah um that was him and the next
day in the speedo who stole your girl
started so great it gets better the next
day i go to lunch at my office and my
co-worker his name was billy i go billy
do you see about the silk road thing it
was powered by like this whole bitcoin
thing and billy goes
yeah my dad like loves it and he thinks
it's going to be huge well billy's last
name billy draper was his name yep and
his dad was tim draper and i
and his dad kind of had a couple of
bitcoins yeah
billy like i wasn't that close to billy
and i try not to talk too much about his
father because you know he's a big deal
and you don't want a fanboy out but
billy was like yeah my dad thinks it's
going to be cool and i was like cool i
don't know anything about this but if
your dad says it's going to be good
yeah i was like i did and so i bought a
bunch of it and then for christmas i
bought each of my family members 200
worth and that turned into 10 grand and
they all laughed at me at the time and
then when i hit 20 g's like a year and a
half ago i go hey mom
log into that thing called coinbase that
i sent you a log into and go take a
vacation and so they all sold it and
took vacations oh they sold it i think
they all sold half yeah just sell half
and have fun
that's awesome and uh that's how i heard
about bitcoin
that may be the best story i've ever
heard it's crazy right yeah um and then
i read the book american kingpin and
they describe my neighborhood i live in
a small neighborhood in san francisco
that very few people know about and i
was it was right like i hang like i sit
at the lot at the seat where he sits all
the time i used to hang out that library
the story of how they got his computer
is crazy they just rushed him when he
like like yeah they distracted him with
like a like a i think a guy in a act
like a guy was hitting this woman or
something yeah and he was turned around
and then they just swarmed them and they
swarmed them and the part that i that
these things they like yeah they like
shoved it across
across the table so you couldn't lock
the computer yeah then they run it to
their van and they plug it into power
which is [ __ ] crazy it was badass and
that's my library i literally lived next
door to that
it was crazy this was crazy i still i
took the photos down off facebook but i
saved them on my dropbox um
it's it's pretty wild to me it's like
having pictures with al capone
you know what i mean yeah like i mean
regardless if you think he did or not
it's like a famous like figurehead for a
person yeah do you ever think i'll get
out
i don't know i don't know where you fall
on this and you're more passionate about
bitcoin i think that if you try to kill
someone
you should go to prison for a really
long time and here's and i also i used
to have these kids that would sell drugs
i lived in soma for a little while and
these these guys would sell drugs and i
hated them for for it they would sell
heroin and i was like you [ __ ] guys
get off my block you're ruining the
neighborhood and then i see him get
arrested and i'm like oh he's this nice
like suburban white kid and i'm like
wait a minute no no no no if i'm mad at
those guys i need to also be mad at this
guy so i think there's a whole thing too
about uh
what drug it is right and i think this
is changing in america in general like
one of the most fascinating trends right
now in culture to me is this idea that
uh like police departments are choosing
what to decriminalize and what not to
they're not gonna go decriminalize
heroin right like like the hardcore
stuff that is very easy to draw a line
to like this is killing people i think
will be illegal for ever if not for a
very very long time period of time
but like marijuana right especially like
small possession of uh or a possession
of smallmouth et cetera you have some
states like california colorado et
cetera who just like look we're from a
legislative standpoint going to say that
this is legal in some cases or just for
anyone but then you have like the
baltimore police who the d.a just was
like hey guys if you keep arresting
people for this i'm not going to
prosecute this in san francisco
you're [ __ ] wasting your time and
that pisses me off because i lived in
the i lived i i lived in glen park for
most of the time i've been there for one
stint i went to soma and then i came
right back and soma you know anything
about san francisco yep okay i was there
for two years it's trashy i mean it's
bad like that's trash everywhere i was
one of the smart ones i lived up in the
north part in like the russian hill okay
i lived in soma and every day i see
these same kids they keep bundles of
heroin in their cheek they can be like
that i told this story before i one time
uh recently was walking in san francisco
about to go into starbucks and i saw a
guy who
again i don't know for sure but it looks
like he's pretty homeless just kind of
really dirty you know clothes kind of
jangled up et cetera and he knelt down
and he put a coffee cup down he took out
an iphone put it on top of the uh coffee
cup like he was holding it there and as
i was coming around the corner to walk
into the store i was kind of looked down
in it well i was like what is this guy
doing right like he's like kneeled down
outside the uh store door and uh he he
had a uh needle yeah again i don't know
if he's actually shooting up right there
or he was just like changing his pocket
or what do you do but i was just like in
what [ __ ] planet do we live with this
guy's got an iphone and a syringe so
look at this i lived outside it was the
same
it was a group of kids from guadalup um
guatemala i think i forget i got to i
started talking to them i kind of
understood how they worked and uh i was
so angry at them because i would see
these i was i lived there for a few
years a couple years and i would see the
same these same people buying drugs i
see them get worse and worse and one day
one of them died on my office doorstep
and i went to like i was like hey can
you please move my employees are coming
and she was dead okay so i got to know
these people and i [ __ ] hated those
drug dealers i hated
i was i don't know who i hated i was
just angry yeah i was pissed off and i
don't know what the right decision is
but i know that if i was if i wanted
those drug dealers arrested which i did
i also you have to
yeah i need to have that towards ross
even though he was this like romantic
good looking like free the people type
of guy like you you have to have it it's
really hard to separate the actions from
the
impact right and i think that there's
also uh there's this community of like
everything should be legalized like you
shouldn't be mad at people who like
create software and marketplaces and all
this stuff but at the same time then
there's this thing of like well if you
know people are selling drugs and people
are getting hurt then like are you
responsible or not which actually is
very similar to like should facebook be
responsible for the content that's on
there like yeah it's every marketplace
owner it's a challenging problem and i
kind of it's really challenging to be
honest i'm i'm kind of a
a little bit of a
i don't take as much time to think about
as i probably should so i have like a
kind of stupid answer to this but it's
like that's a super complex issue that's
above my pay grade and i actually don't
know what the answer is which is cop out
right but like well there is no answer
there's there's let's try this and see
and there's a spectrum of like there's
the hardcore believers on one end
there's a hardcore believers on another
end and there's everyone that's in the
middle and like they all disagree and
that's where you get all of the but
don't forget he tried to kill three
people and they thought he killed one he
thought he killed a couple of them and
then kept going right yeah so like
that's a whole separate issue of course
so
um as much as i stole your girl like
that that might be the most important
part is sasha i remember it specifically
um
i don't think she's listening to this
but um
yeah so my thing is like i i loved
reading about his book and i it was such
good writing that i was like yeah go
ross like but then you got to like take
your emotions out of it be like
i mean
yeah a lot of bad stuff so it's really
challenging hey guys bang bang thanks so
much for watching the best business show
today and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.compomp
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.com pomp and make sure
you come back and watch more of the best
business show we're going to build the
biggest business show in the world and
we need your help